हेलो फ्रेंड्स नमस्कार चमन सीखे हिंदी में
के वृक्ष एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
एडवांस या फिर भी वनप्लस लेवल की कंफर्म
सीखने वाले हैं तेल का मूल्यों पर यह
कंसेप्ट सीखने से पहले मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि आप यह तभी आए जबकि आपके सारे भी
वन लेवल तक के कंसेप्ट मतलब जो पहले
फोर्टिफाई एपिसोड्स है उनके घर कंसेप्ट्स
आपके क्लियर है तो ही आप यह एपिसोड देखिए
कि दी स्कल्पचर गिरगिट वे हैव इट्स मोरल
सॉफ्ट रूल पहले फोर्टिफाई एपिसोड ज्यादा
इंपोर्टेंट है अगर आपके वह परफेक्ट हुए
हैं तो यह आप यह वीडियो देख चल तो हम शुरू
करते हैं टैक्स का मोल लिखने को थोड़ा सा
हाथ लगता है रियर कामों किया है बट
बेसिकली ए वेरी सिंपल कंसेप्ट तेल मतलब
टेंपुरा स्कैनर फॉर शॉर्ट फॉर्म तेल मतलब
टेंपोरल मतलब कब का मतलब का यूजर मतलब
क्यों मोड मतलब मोडल मतलब कैसे
है और लो मतलब लोग कार मतलब कहा यह क्या
है हम डिटेल में आगे देखेंगे पर यह जो
कंसेप्ट है उसके बाद आपको थोड़ी सी हिंदी
की अनुमति देता हूं तो आपको थोड़ा समझ में
आएगा तो थे कोई एग्जांपल मैं बताता हूं
आपको मैं साइकिल से सुभाष स्कूल जाता हूं
या फिर मैं सुबह साइकिल से स्कूल जाता हूं
या फिर सुबह में साइकिल से स्कूल जाता हूं
ऑल थ्री लुक सारे जैसे रखते हैं अनुसार
करेक्ट रखते हैं क्यों कि हिंदी का मेन
किया है कि वह जाता हूं एंड में चाहिए वह
बैंक में चाहिए फिर आगे आप थोड़ा इधर-उधर
कि तो चलेगा एक्चुअली हिंदी के भी इसके
रूल्स हैं कि पहले सुबह आना चाहिए यह पहले
मैं आना चाहिए पर वह मोस्ट ऑफिस डोंट नो
दो जरूज और उससे ज्यादा फर्क भी नहीं
पड़ता तो वैसे ही जर्मन के भी रूल से और
वॉच व है वह यह टेप कामों टेक मोर जनरल
कीवर्ड्स और जो है आपके सेंटेंसेस कि वह
डिपेंड करता है तो अब हम
फिल्म देखते हैं टीम का आर्म होल ओके
टेंपो ट्रैवलर मतलब क्या कोई चीज कब हो
रही है समुद्र ठंडे हो रही है मंडे हो रही
है तो आप मोंटाग यह माइलेज वगैरह होता है
टेंपो फिर होता है कौन सा हल्का अवसर
उपलब्ध किस लिए हो रही है कि वह गेंद और
बट काम के लिए और इसलिए अब मतलब आउट ऑफ लव
में यह कर रहा हूं यह हो गए री संग फ्रेम
मॉडल कैसे प्रकार से जा रहे हो बस से जा
रहे हैं कुछ मिट डेमो टू मीडियम बॉस और
लास्ट में लोकल कहां पर इंस्पीरोन या फिर
ना खबर लेकिन यह सब है लोकल तो यह जो सारे
कम पॉइंट है वह आपके किस क्रम में आएंगे
यह टेक अमोल रूल डिपेंड करता है अब एक मैं
बहुत बड़ा तुझे अगर हम नया कंसेप्ट सीख
रहे हैं तो उल्टे द वर्स्ट के तो सबसे
बड़ा यह चारों कंपोनेंट है 6:00 सेंटेंस
लेते हैं
है और फिर मैं आपको यह एक्सप्लेन करता हूं
तो फिर छोटे पार्ट तो एकदम इजी ओके तो
देखो अगर आपको ऐसे बोलना है कि मुझे आज
सोमवार को काम काम से अकाश शिकार के साथ
बरलिन जाना पड़ेगा अगर आपको ऐसे बोलना है
कि आसमान अधिक गो टू बरलिन ऑन मंडे दिसंबर
विकार तो वह जर्मन में कैसे करोगे देखो
शुरुआत में तो आपको पता है जर्मन का मेन
रोल क्या है सेकेंड पोजीशन पर चलने वाला व
और अगर वह कप मोड ऑन है तो मेन व एक दम
एंड में तो अगर मैं चाहता हूं तो इस पारद
होता पर अभी इस मुजफ्फर है तो इश मुसंबी
बीच में तारा खिचड़ी और एंड में पारण और
अभिषेक को पहने के बुलाया स्टेडियमों
हॉलों तो सबसे पहले का या सोमवार इशू
मुसलमाम मॉडल इस अमाउंट आफ उसके बाद क्या
यह क्यों चाहता हूं काम के लिए वे
एंड्राइड इससे आम मोंटा विजेंद्र और उसके
बाद किया है देखो मॉडल कैसे करूं कार से
मिट गए माउंट और एंड में कहां जाता हूं पर
ले जाता हूं नागपुर
है तो क्या होगा इस मूस
कि आम मोंटाग केंद्र और विड्थ हिम टो नाक
बरलिन फौरन सिर्फ इतनी बड़ी ट्रेल एकदम
फिट लग पर आप जनरल इतने बड़े सेंटर चारों
उसके यह करके बोलते ही नहीं जगत सिंपल
सेंटेंस बोलता है कि सोमवार को मुझे मैं
जब नुंबर ले जाऊंगा या फिर मैं काम के
सिलसिले में भरली जाऊंगा या फिर मैं
सोमवार को काम के लिए बदल जाऊंगा इतना या
बोलते हैं जैसे मैं कार से बदल जाऊंगा तो
यह छोटे टुकड़े हैं वह भी अगर वैसे ही
जर्मन में करोगे पर अगर टेगा वालों में
सिर्फ जो भी टुकड़े आपके पॉसिबल है वह आप
उसी क्रम मिलोगे तो अगर आपको बोलना है कि
वह ई इश्कम और इसमें रिसर्च आम मॉनिटर
नागौर इनफॉर्म इतना ही है
मैं तुझे देखा आपके पास क्या था टेंपो
रास्ता और लोग कांत इट्स प्रैक्टिस
मुसलमाम मोंटाग ने खबर इनफॉर्म वह क्रम
वैसे ही रखना है समझ में आया तो आप बोलोगे
फिर भी थोड़ा सा यह लग रहा है तुझे को
पहली चीज यह प्रैक्टिस के साथ आएगा दूसरी
चीज क्या है कि जनरल ने लिखते वक्त आपको
थोड़ा केयर लेना पड़ता है बोलते वस्तु यह
में डोंट उसका ज्यादा और विचार हम करते ही
नहीं कि अगर आप देखोगे हिंदी में भी आप
कभी कभी बोलते हो सुबह मैं स्कूल जाता हूं
मैं सुबह स्कूल जाता हूं और फिर स्कूल
मुस्कुरा जाता हूं ऑल SIM करेक्ट वैसे यह
जर्मन बैकरी जब वह किसी चीज से इंपल्सेस
देना होता है कि यह जो है यह जो न्यूट्रल
और अगर आपको नार्मल लिखना है तो यह बॉर्डर
टिकते कामों पर अगर आपको किसी चीज पर जोर
देना है कि सुबह मुझे स्कूल जाता हूं या
साइकिल से मैं स्कूल जाता हूं तो उसको उसी
पोजिशन चेंज कर सक
हिंदी में वे सिर्फ जर्मन में करते हो जब
जर्मंस को आदत है कि कभी-कभी वह पहले
पोजीशन पर टाइम लेते हैं मतलब इस वेरी
कॉमन टेस्ट से आम मॉनिटर परेशनाथ भर लें
आम मॉनिटर परेशनाथ बदले कंपलीटली करेक्ट
सेंटेंस है कि अपना जर्मन करूंगी क्या है
सेकेंड पोजीशन पर वर्ग अभी पहले से अपने
सिर हमेशा सब्जेक्ट पहला रखना सीखा कि
आपको इजी पड़े पर अगर आप किस लेवल पर आगे
तो आपको यह समझना है कि हमारा रूल है
सेकेंड पोजीशन पर वह इसलिए आम वांट टो
वर्क फॉर नेशनल अकबर अली ने इस परफेक्टली
हो कि आखिर जैसे न पहले सेंटेंस अगर आपको
है इसमें कि मुझे यह इंपोर्टेंट के काम के
सिलसिले में मुझे इंपोर्टेंट है तो अब वे
केंद्र एग वाइट को पहले लागी वह सेंटेंस
बना सकते हो अगर इन ऑल दोस्त पर टाइम को
पॉसिबिलिटीज अ पॉसिबल तो अगर कोई रूल है
कि जो हंड्रेड परसेंट अप्लाई करना जरूरी
नहीं है तो और
है इसीलिए उसको टेंडेंसी बोलते हैं
स्टेडियम और वे नॉट मोर रूल इट्स ए
टेंडेंसी फिर इसीलिए मैं बोलता हूं कि
सर्विस बिट्टू Nokia गिरफ्त बीटू हो सी-1
और अगर आपको कोई पूछेगा मुल्क पता नहीं
क्या तुम लोग हो यार इसको टीकमगढ़ नहीं
पता लग यह पीएसपीओ नहीं जानता कि तरह खो
जाता है तो यह आई नो थिस रूल की वाइफ
टेंपोरल का उज्जवल मोड ऑन लोकल क्या है
कौन सा पहले आना चाहिए मुझे पता है बट यस
मैं यह सीखूंगा जैसे जैसे मैंने यूज करते
जाऊंगा वैसे में सीख लूंगा और थोड़ा अगर
इधर-उधर हो भी गया तो इन जनरल आईएस नॉट ए
बिग मिस्टेक सामने वाला हूं समझ सकता है
100 इंटरनेशनल में फिर से बताता हूं कि
टेक्नो इस मोर एफर्ट एंड सी इज नॉट टो रूल
तो यह डोंट वरी अगर वह थोड़ा इधर-उधर हो
गया बट ई हैव सीखने के लिए हम सीखेंगे कि
जर्मन लैंग्वेज में अगर आपके पास
कुंदन वन पार्ट है तो आप पहले क्या लोगे
टेंपोरल कब मोडक उज्जवल क्यों मॉडल कैसे
और लोकल मतलब कहां आगे अगर आपको यह हो गई
न्यूट्रल वर्ड ऑर्डर अगर आपको किसी चीज पर
इंपल्सेस देना है तो आप उसको आगे ले जा
सकते हो मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको यह कैंसर
समझ आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड
में धन्यवाद